what do you think about Elon buying
Twitter
so in this perfect balance optimized
reallocation of tornadoes throughout uh
the various efforts in human
civilization uh do you think do you
worry about his involvement with Twitter
I mean personally I just I I see that as
a lot less important than and personally
for me inspirational than Starship and
you know the work done at SpaceX and
Tesla to me those were two very
uh impactful and really really just
generally like you know they're uniting
like you know something to Rally around
get excited about rally and just like a
future to look forward to yeah
um you know the idea of we're gonna be
building the world's most powerful
biggest rocket ever and it's eventually
going to be able to get humans on Mars
for the first time and we're gonna
transition the world into fully
sustainable awesome just totally badass
cars that do all these cool things to me
those were like that brought a sense of
unity and a sense of like we can do this
personally I just don't think that a
social media no matter what it is I
don't see that in a social media and I
don't I don't see
um any sort of politicking as ever
anything that's really every uniting
thing I understand that I totally agree
with you especially space how inspiring
it is I have to push back I do think
the impact of social media
the basic level of uh
meaningful connections of this
collective intelligence that we call
human civilization through the medium of
you know digital communication which is
social media I think that can have a
huge impact it could be the very vehicle
that increases the inspiration that
SpaceX doesn't and all different uh the
thing I've criticized them a bunch for
is like why bring politics into this uh
so the political the political divisions
that we see on Twitter feeding them
It's Tricky
um It's tricky to sort of understand
what is the value of that what is the
contribution of that to uh to this whole
effort with God going on so there's been
a that that's been a big challenge but
that said like again this tornado
the number of tornadoes and social media
I think is really important because
social media has such a huge impact on
on us as a society and to have a
transparent
um have a bit of turmoil
you know it's like Tom way says I like
my town with a bit of Drop of Poison
with a little Drop of Poison so like a
little bit of that
um shake things up I think might be
really healthy I just worry about the
long-term impact on the whole Mars
project through that and so but you know
what
uh this life one of the reasons that's
fun is uh
through the chaos you like none of us
know how it's going to turn out and hope
hopefully we try to help each other to
make sure it turns out well and and this
really isn't like anything about my
personal like politics or anything like
that but really just generally any of my
friends that are like the first thing
you hear about them in their day is
something that happened in politics or
something that some world leaders doing
or not doing or saying and not saying
I just don't find that to be the most
important thing really
um I I know that obviously that can
affect a lot of people that has big real
world consequences politics do
but like I just re and this is just me
I'm such a like he'll come together you
know Cheerio kind of guy
that I just really think like you need
something bigger than bickering about
what you know what people said and did
and what they've voted on and all this
stuff to to Really push Humanity forward
like I you know I know that politics and
and their and and by extracting that
social media can affect things like
space flight and even our like planetary
defense like being able to defend
ourselves against asteroids like if
politics has their way and everything
goes to crap and we don't even get to
you know yeah we're not going to be able
to you know continue space flight and
things like that but like I don't know I
just think there's better ways to do it
and more uniting ways to do it than
than you know what feels like a mature
name calling sometimes you know yeah I
think the political bickering that most
people talk about that that's on top of
most people's minds is the thing they'll
be completely forgotten by history it
has actually very little impact yes
politics matters but like one percent of
it I think most of it is just
political bickering the push and pull of
the red team and the blue team and the
and then it the uh the news media that
feeds off the division for the attention
and it's just like a fun athletic event
almost with the with the blue team and
the red team so 100 you kind of have to
have a historical perspective on it like
most things
uh will not really have a significant
impact and we should focus on
development of science technology
engineering which is the thing that
grows the pie 100 this is just this is
what the economists know well yeah which
is the Innovation the engineering that's
what actually makes everybody richer
yeah it's kind of political bickering
it's just eating the pie and not just
richer but it improves their lives you
know we we can look at every modern
technology that is bestowed upon us
today air conditioning electricity
internet access fresh clean water
running water blah blah blah you know
100 years ago so many of the things that
I listed either didn't exist or were
only accessible by the ultra wealthy you
know and it's through the innovation of
Technology and Engineering and education
that we're able to
have it be that even someone below the
poverty line and the most of the
developed world will have a good number
of those things in their life um and
that's just continuing to increase and
continue to get better
so I I think yeah that's to me that's
in the grand scheme more important but
um to each their own